and the rocket hit again, unfortunately, there are
victims again, dead and injured people, burnt
houses in Zaporizhzhia after the first
rocket strike today, when people
came to clear the debris, Russia
launched a second missile strike, absolute
meanness, absolute evil,
there have already been thousands of manifestations of such evil,
unfortunately, there may be thousands more at
first  I didn't understand anything, I managed to
throw a blanket over myself and
shrapnel flew at me, at first there was a
misunderstanding, everything was in a fog, I didn't understand
anything at all, first of all, the admiration for
our Zaporizhia nuclear power plant is
already using it for blackmail
in conversations of pressure on Europe on Ukraine
first of all, this is already nuclear blackmail, I
think so because the station is now
disconnected. Look at it. Both from the point of
view of security and then from the point of view of
pragmatism, and then and there you will see that this is
blackmail and a crisis. What is nuclear blackmail in the
fact that you can blackmail  not only
because you use nuclear weapons, you
can blackmail because the nuclear power
plant, nuclear blocks do not work  are affecting
society and people are not getting warmth,
especially now it can be a big crisis
and not only for Ukraine and for Europe,
be sure the head of Russia is now carefully
analyzing the world's reaction to the
pseudo-referendums he arranged on Ukrainian land
to the announcement of the annexation of our
territory,
what exactly interests him  he is simply
interested in whether he still has the potential for
escalation, if the reaction of the world is now
weak, Russia is coming up with some new
escalation, you see that the spectrum of criminal
actions of this state is very, very wide